we just go sorry I hope I think we all
know the emergency evacuation people who
can hear thunder and have colleges
rascals murcheson sewing and help
support this is capable so you're so
fake i could hardly hear ya right any
declarations of interest any questions
are notice no emotions of emotions right
we'll start with found item 74
introduced the art of a [ __ ] just
introduce our representatives from BD
arts and law duties which had been to
found Cena previous meetings is our
partner and he retires at the end of
March thank you Richard for your work on
an accountant good luck future wow thank
you for me as well and BTW oh this is
their last year 1415 auditing the
council's accounts and subsidy claim ey
will be taken over for the 1516
financial year but just to tide us over
the last few months David Eagles would
be the partner on VTO looking after this
account he worked on our cow five years
previously so he will knows the council
yes said he's just kind of long to see
no the face and he'll be at the next
urgent committee look I am so item 7 is
just an update on the recommendations
that BG I made were after they all do at
the 2013-14 accounts and the appendix
just provides an update on where we are
they're all completed except for the
marketplace a calls item on page seven
point three and then I'll be treated
until after the end of the financial
year home to a gorgeous ask a question
on the marketplace accruals notice those
are duplicated up order was the cost
involved / minimal or was it a large
order it was an original to it was quite
a large order it was it was reported in
to audit committee as a specific amount
but can't remember the details it was
planning policy order and they just used
a different description when they raised
the second part of the order and there
was just a bit confusion so there was no
actual payment at the council which just
being cool that was duplicated is picked
up by the external auditors like I think
here everybody happy
the recommendation it is proposed that
committee result of monitoring sheets on
video recommendations arising from the
annual governor's report 2013-14 be
agreed right item 8 apps park videos
work and they all did the subsidy claims
housing benefits subsidy and business
roads and Valium Housing Benefit subsidy
claim is about 17 point seven million
and this report just highlights the
errors that they found in the testing
but I have Richard loves to just give a
bit of perspective to young volunteers
yes but of course this this work is very
very detailed as you'll see from the
description yeah we have to look at term
what's called an initial sample of this
case about for the individual cases and
examine them in great detail if I wish
the works done by the council I should
send we sort of checked it but
nonetheless the work is very detailed
and which is why you'll see that we have
sort of very detailed comments and your
report here about what we be found on on
each case the rules are very complex and
so the all councils unfortunately do
make mistakes in applying them there are
many rules that have to apply to each
case and we have to devote all of the
rules and to put it into context I think
as the Rochford was certainly one of the
better ones that I have done this year
there are
many that are sort of far worse reports
than this one this is quite a good
report actually although there are a
number of pages of detailed matters in
the report so I just wanted to give that
context really that actually and your
Oxford benefits section actually he's
doing pretty good work actually there is
no no there is something that I'd like
to come up from where on page two of
three Falls and the testing of initial
samples porch one cases identified ten
hours where there's like twenty five
percent but then it you know you did go
further with the testing and what you're
saying is that you're quite happy with
it yes yeah I mean that 10 out of 41
yeah twenty-five percent it does seem it
seems that I error rate was trying to
put it in context ready to start with
because there are quite a few aspects of
each case your look at so and while in
an ideal world every aspect every case
would be absolutely correct the
imbalance involved are generally very
very small and you'll see that I think
from some of the in some of the cases
here we do actually quantify them so it
isn't as bad as it appears it's or
twenty five percent of the cases are
wrong match for them but we do defer the
work yes and we then go on to make reach
conclusion on the larger samples in this
case after the larger samples social
40-plus have few errors the initial
sample so
I hope again they put it into bit of
context Thank You counselor Christine
thanks um thank you the best one
Unilever years baseman here and okay I
don't mind yeah I've listened to the
complexity and I agree that the
complexity of the this system is amazed
and I think the errors are very minor
and I think we should applaud the staff
actually for the amount that is correct
rather than focusing on the ones that
are incorrect however just a small point
at the underpayments that these are
often the most vulnerable people have we
had any feedback I'm pleased to see that
then corrected I think that's a great
but have we had any feedback for the
affected claimants to the effect that it
has affected them or no feedback on that
account for dumping I'm not aware of
anything and I haven't seen that formal
complaints about it I was thinking the
amounts are so mind that it's probably
not but it and they are corrective which
is the major thing thank you for sharing
um I appreciate it the sums in boelter
minimal but why is it we have to wait
for external just to highlight this and
we can't fix
these things are from you tell me is
their reasoning or easy you know I know
I don't know it's just the volume of
it's a really heavily transactional
based area of work and I think with the
move to zero hours contracts and
real-time information where HMRC are now
getting the information from payrolls
monthly which is getting such a high
volume of change of circumstances that
you just start you know claims are being
changed of almost kind of weekly and
monthly so it's just the volume of
claims there are quality checks so the
revs and Ben's teams themselves quality
checks the work but you know someone
justice will slip through and then
internal audit and which said done most
of its testing so they found the young
yeah is internally but fortunately I
yeah is there anything is there so I a
reason that some of these things are
slipping through each human errors a new
people into the jobs is it I don't know
it'll be human error I mean sometimes
its confusion about start date we found
it in the past but you know people just
you know a song moves into a house what
date G counts the first day of
occupation as it first of all day that
they're there or the day that they
actually move into the property so I
think you can just be confusion over
definitions so really providing me told
all the staff the same thing the first
dye user first I they movie and II was
made you they move in at six o'clock in
the aid in that fancy it's just the
volume of them changes that have been
processed by the teams but they are I
think they're pretty hot on training
down there and they will pull up when
they monitor individual staff their
error rates
okay and we gon page three yeah got
turned back to David was saying actually
chop it where it resulted in 226 pounds
decrease in the amount of something
payable as you were saying Lesley oh
you're on that we're a bit concerned
that some of these people are very
vulnerable as you were saying I'm 226
pound is quite an amount about a month
is my honor as you don't answer to this
one yeah this one is the same as the
scheme called in on HR righty where we
can claim a certain amount back from the
DWP and the rest we carry what was one
actually done is if they the amount that
was set was wrong but it didn't impact
on the claimant got the right money but
it was a matter it was an accounting
thing with what we can claim back from
the DWP okay that's fine any more
questions on page three page ball
hey six what's shuttle 12 your degree
then the recommendations proposed that
the country resolves that the grads
claiming returns you to give the 2013-14
vinos write um um write 9.1 and I've had
quite a long discussion with Yvonne
regarding 3.3 where there's an invoice
query and this is an ongoing thing so
I'd like a clinician that we brought it
up but it's something that we're going
to have to come back to for their future
date so you happy with that so the
recommendation is proposing the
committee resolves that revised faulty
plans 2014-15 beer braid right okay
everyone my one by name again and I
noticed it in I love it I do beg you one
another I'm sorry I will go to the wrong
one I draw that okay Evan so there's no
queries they have been the
recommendation it is proposed that the
committee resolves that the shared or
business the Audit Committee 2015 16 v
9t person public world in on the clock